[Música]
tudo o que eu vou falar resultado da
minha pesquisa corpo envelhecimento
felicidade com 5 mil homens e mulheres
de 18 a 96 anos
atualmente eu estou pesquisando só
aqueles que já passaram dos 90 anos
vocês já ouviram falar da curva da
felicidade
pesquisas realizadas por economistas em
80 países com mais de 2 milhões de
pessoas
descobrir um padrão constante as pessoas
mais jovens e as mais velhas são as mais
felizes e as que se sentem menos felizes
são aquelas que estão entre 40 e 50 anos
os pesquisadores descobriram uma curva
da felicidade no formato da letra o
a felicidade é maior no início da vida
começa a diminuir ao longo dos anos
chegando ao seu ponto mais baixo em
torno dos 45 anos e depois começa a
subir
as pessoas mais velhas
se tiver em boa saúde e estabilidade
financeira e afetiva podem se sentir tão
felizes quanto as mais jovens
eu também encontrei uma curva da
felicidade nas mulheres brasileiras que
eu venho pesquisando há mais de 30 anos
as que têm entre 40 e 50 anos são as que
se sentem mais infelizes insatisfeitas
frustradas deprimidas e exaustas
elas reclamam principalmente de falta d
um pouco a falta de reconhecimento e de
falta de liberdade
algumas ainda dizem que falta tudo
quando eu perguntei para as mulheres o
que elas mais inveja nos homens
elas disseram em primeiríssimo lugar
liberdade em segundo lugar mas disseram
fazer xixi em pé
elas também inveja liberdade masculina
com o próprio corpo
a liberdade sexual a liberdade de rir de
brincar de qualquer bobagem e muitas
outras liberdades quando eu perguntei
aos homens o que eles mais inveja nas
mulheres
eles responderão simplesmente nada
quando perguntei para as mulheres o que
elas mais inveja em outras mulheres
elas disseram corpo/beleza juventude
magreza e sensualidade
o corpo invejado por elas é jovem magro
e sensual no brasil este modelo de corpo
é um verdadeiro capital
as mulheres brasileiras são as que mais
fazem no mundo cirurgia plástica
preenchimento botox remédios para dormir
remédios para emagrecer moderadores de
apetite tinturas para cabelo e
ansiolíticos são as que estão mais
insatisfeitas com o próprio corpo
as que mais deixam de sair de casa de a
festas e até mesmo de trabalhar quando
se sentem velhas e gordas e feias
não é à toa que as brasileiras têm um
verdadeiro
pânico de envelhecer como disse uma
professora de 45 anos ela dizendo a
minha mão a crise foi quando eu fiz 40
anos entrou em pânico porque está
ficando velha
não sei se eu faço cirurgia plástica ou
botox preenchimento vocês eu posso
continuar usando minissaia e biquíni
tenho medo que me chamem de velha
ridícula
eu estou na fase de será que eu posso
sou uma mulher invisível uma mulher
transparente uma mulher nem nem jovem
nem velha mas eu tenho uma ótima notícia
para vocês
tudo começa a melhorar e muito
depois dos 50 anos ea curva da
felicidade começa a subir
as mulheres de mais de 60 anos que eu
pesquisei disseram tá teoricamente este
é o melhor momento de toda a minha vida
nunca fui tão feliz
é a primeira vez na vida que eu posso
ser eu mesma nunca foi tão livre e como
será que elas conquistaram a liberdade
tão desejada
vocês querem matar dicas que elas me da
anata em primeiro lugar
elas descobriram que o tempo é o
verdadeiro capital
elas não querem não podem mais
desperdiçar o próprio tempo
as mulheres mais jovens quer agradar
todo mundo cuida de todo mundo e reclama
que não tem tempo pra elas mais velhas
elas passa a priorizar o tempo para
cuidar delas mesmas
para isso elas tiveram que aprender a
dizer não uma coisa que parece muito
simples mas não é
aprender a dizer não é uma verdadeira
revolução para as mulheres
elas também fizeram uma verdadeira face
chineses tendencial a faxina não é só
jogar fora aquelas roupas que não servem
mais os cacarecos aquelas coisas que a
gente não quer mais na nossa vida isso
também é importante mas é mais fácil a
faxina existencial é tirar das nossas
vidas todas aquelas pessoas que só fazem
mal que só criticam que só sugam a nossa
energia os verdadeiros vampiros
emocionais
elas também aprenderam a ligar o botão
do forró de si não é que elas ficam
dizendo pra todo mundo
por que os outros pensam não é
isso elas são muito elegantes
é muito mais uma atitude interna vão
dizer que eu sou uma velha ridícula
porque eu vou à praia de biquíni
vão dizer que eu sou uma velha baranga
porque eu gosto de usar minissaia vão
dizer também que eu sou uma coroa
piriguete porque o namoro com cara mais
jovem
e se for das interno é libertador
vocês querem experimentar
elas também falaram muito da importância
das amigas são as amigas que cuidam que
escutam que conversa que leva ao médico
que telefonam todos os dias para saber
como elas estão elas falaram muito mais
das amigas do que do marido dos filhos e
dos netos quando eu perguntei para as
mulheres quem vai cuidar de você na
velhice
elas disseram em primeiro lugar eu mesma
em seguida elas disseram minhas amigas
quando eu perguntei os homens quem vai
cuidar de você na velhice
ele responderá minha esposa minhas
filhas
minhas netas por fim elas aprender a rir
e brincar muito mais 60% das mulheres
mais jovens que eu pesquisei disseram
que inveja capacidade masculina de rede
blindada de qualquer bobagem
bela tenta vocês não têm mais que eu não
tenho tempo que eu tenho muito medo do
que os outros vão pensar mais velhas
elas aprendem a ria muito baixa
especialmente rio delas mesmas
como disse uma médica de 65 anos
olha que ela disse não sei porque eu
demorei tanto tempo para descobrir uma
coisa tão simples que liberdade é a
melhor rima para a felicidade minha
receita para uma vida feliz a ter
projetos de vida
não me preocupar com o que os outros
pensam dizer não para tudo o que eu não
quero mais na minha vida e curtir as
minhas amigas como médico eu posso
garantir e muito principalmente rede mim
mesma é sempre o melhor remédio
eu quero terminar então como a pergunta
pra vocês
porque será que demoramos tanto tempo
para descobrir uma coisa tão simples que
a melhor rima para a felicidade é
liberdade e que ia muito principalmente
rir de nós mesmas
é sempre o melhor remédio
[Aplausos]